n'est venu merci d'être avec pont direct
sur arte france alors sans vous prêter
des dons de visionnaire en selon quelle
sera l'issue de ce débat au parlement
pakistanais
effectivement ne me prêtez pas des dons
de deux visionnaires parce que c'est en
réalité ce débat au parlement qui avait
été une promesse faite par le premier
ministre à l'égard des militants du tlp
cette organisation extrêmement sensible
la question du blasphème
c'est aussi un piège pour l'opposition
la politique parce que la question du
blasphème est extrêmement sensible vous
l'avez dit donc c'est aussi une façon de
piéger les groupes de l'opposition dans
un pays où les relations entre le
pouvoir et l'opposition sont
particulièrement tendues pour autant il
faut rappeler que vous l'avez dit
l'origine de cette série de
manifestations qui ont mobilisé beaucoup
de monde sont liées à la sphère samuel
paty et à ce qu'a été la position du
président français sur cette affaire à
savoir défendre le droit et la liberté
de caricature alors que ce kid
évidemment d'un côté définit comme droit
à la caricature de l'autre côté est
défini comme étant blasphématoire et
contre la sanctification quelque sorte
du prophète donc le pouvoir de
mobilisation de la rue était très
important mais ce n'est pas la première
fois que ça se passe le mouvement est
derrière tout cela qui a été interdite
alors que le gouvernement a recommencé à
négocier avec lui dès le lendemain
d'ailleurs la séance du parlement
hier et aujourd'hui quand on connais pas
encore le résultat fait partie de cette
négociation est en jeu évidemment
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur de france
demandes des manifestants réitérée de
longue date mais évidemment le premier
ministre et le gouvernement comprennent
très bien que s'il cédait sur ce point
ça créerait un incident diplomatique est
dans un discours à la nation le premier
ministre ibrahim khan a rappelé il ya
quelques jours que des caricatures ça
pouvait venir demain ou après-demain
d'un autre pays de l'union européenne et
que le risque était se mettre à dos les
européens alors que l'union européenne
est un partenaire commercial décisif
pour les exportations pakistanaise je ne
suis pas sûr que cet argumentaire soit
reçue mais en tout cas le gouvernement
la joue un peu avec le feu parce que sur
la question du de la semaine les très
difficile de prendre des positions
modérées je dirais sur la question est
donc chacun au pakistan regardent avec
intérêt ce que sera la résolution des
parlementaires étant entendu que la
résolution des parlementaires n'impose
pas d'obligation d'actions auprès du
gouvernement est la position de
gouvernants en tout cas dit morano
qu'alain qu'interdit mlle telle paix
mais qui finalement partage certaines de
ses positions
est ce qu'il est vraiment plaire non
évidemment sa position est confuse
quand il était dans l'opposition dans
une autre sphère lié à une question de
blasphème imran khan avait attaqué le
gouvernement du moment
en prenant des positions qui n'était pas
très éloignée de celle de ce fameux tlp
la question si vous voulez tellement
sensible que elle est forcément piégé
pour pour des gouvernements mais là
évidemment l'opposition lui rétorque
d'enfin vous avez négocié avec ces gens
pendant des mois sans qu'on sache
exactement ce qui a été négocié
vous les interdisez et vous continuez à
négocier avec le lendemain bien sûr la
position est très inconfortable pour le
premier ministre est d'une certaine
façon ils espèrent se défausser sur les
parlementaires
il ya déjà des parties un parti
d'opposition majeure qui a dit nous on
ne jouerait pas ce jeu là il fallait
nous mettre dans la boucle
au moment même des négociations entamées
avec ses militants et donc le point
d'interrogation reste totalement ouvert
pour le moment on est dans la
supposition ans les débats ne font pas
terminé on n'a pas encore la réponse
mais admettons que l'ambassadeur
français soient expulsés du pakistan à
quel point ça va brouiller les deux pays
pakistan et france dans la tradition
diplomatique sino baladeur est expulsé
son pays va évidemment rétorqué en
expulsant l'ambassadeur pakistanais en
france mais au delà évidemment ça posera
probablement le problème d'image pour le
pakistan
or le pakistan est aujourd'hui dans une
situation qu'il faut prendre dans son
ensemble c'est à dire que il y a les
évolutions très incertaine en
afghanistan avec la grande conférence
d'istanbul qui était supposée avancée
qui a été retardé les taliban afghans ne
voulons pas céder aux américains les
pakistanais ou un rôle à jouer là dessus
et puis lire la tradition
gouvernement pakistanais d'appui à des
groupes jihadistes qui pose un problème
auprès d'une instance internationale qui
s'appelle le groupe d'action financière
qui lutte contre le financement du
terrorisme le pakistan est sur la liste
grise
s'il tombait sur la liste noire ça
interdirait les prêts du fonds monétaire
international qui sont sollicités en ce
moment donc qu évidemment le pouvoir
veut calmer la rue d'un côté et de
l'autre côté soigner son image c'est un
exercice assez complexe jean luc racine
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
recherche émérite au cnrs et chercheur
senior à l'asia centre spécialiste de
l'inde et du pakistan marciac